remember she's not a girl I'm a
[Music]
shark I uh want to cap off my video this
week with a look at adaptation partly
having to do with this is uh band Book
week if you weren't already aware and
while I'm not particularly certain if uh
the book we're going to be talking about
and it you know the adaptation
subsequent to it has actually been
banned in the past it might only just be
because it's uh themes that would get it
banned in places like Florida are a
little below the surface I've already
talked about the film neona in fact I
dedicated a whole video on why that
movie is Absol absolutely phenomenal but
I want to go a layer deeper and I want
to talk about how good it is as an
adaptation and this one I'm really
excited to talk about CU I've talked
about adaptations intermittently I
talked about the Watchmen adaptation a
while back and how excessive loyalty to
the source material actually hurt the
story I've talked about the adaptation
of Neil game and Sandman and how it is
incredibly loyal to the source material
but makes a number of incredibly smart
changes selectively pona is an even more
unique case I think because it is in my
mind without a doubt a masterful
adaptation that
deviates heavily when it comes to story
and plot and even some of the characters
are quite different but regardless it is
such a good adaptation of of the heart
of the original work now couple things
before I get into this this is not going
to be a blowby blow list of the
differences between the original graphic
novel and the movie that's not what I'm
here to do there are other YouTubers who
do that hint hint Dominic Noble please
do a lost and adaptation of pneumonia if
it's not already on your docket but
that's not what I'm doing I'm not going
blow for blow and telling you what every
differen is I will be highlighting
differences but only as a way to talk
about the way they were changed and why
these were smart adaptational changes
that explains literally nothing now this
does mean that by necessity I'm going to
be spoiling the movie
and the
book this book is real good and even if
you've seen the
movie you really should read this cuz it
is quite different let's talk a little
bit about what this book is and then get
into the adapt ations and how it's smart
nimona was the first published work by
ND Stevenson also goes by Nate Stevenson
now Nate Stevenson at a quite young age
started doing neona as a web comic and
finished the story it got compiled and
released as a graphic novel now his
history as a web comic already leads to
some interesting quirks such as the uh
continued Improvement of the art style
when he first started Ed the art style
was fairly simplistic but you can see as
it goes it gets more sophisticated
especially the coloring of it and that's
really fascinating to watch and in a way
it kind of enhances the story as you get
to know these characters deeper as the
story honestly gets a bit more serious
as opposed to its lighter tone at the
front end my initial guess was in fact
that that was done on purpose I found
out later it was just a happy accident
because he was getting more confident in
his art abilities as he continued this
story but you read it all compiled and
it just starts out while very clearly
still being in the same style but starts
out a bit more rough a bit looser and
then just gets more sophisticated more
streamlined it kind of Suits the story
in an odd way and the other thing that
is really important and we're going to
circle back onto this and highlight it
um while he was not fully aware of the
exact direction of where his journey was
going to take him Nate Stevenson was
working through a fair bit of gender
related things as he worked on this
because Nate Stevenson is a uh
transmasculine
individual and he didn't have that fully
sorted by the time pona was done and
published I didn't know what I was doing
when I first started drawing Comics over
a decade ago I just knew that my
emotions were too big for my body and I
had to put them somewhere from these
feelings a character began to emerge I
named her pona for no particular reason
it just felt right I didn't think I
deserved love but maybe she did to look
at this he was very clearly working
through some things and or at least
starting to so that is very much present
in the work and we're going to get into
that a little bit more but broadly
speaking I'm kind of assuming that you
know at least the movie if not both as I
move forward but broad overview in a uh
Kingdom that is a mix of fantasy and
largely present day technology like
there's smartphones you can get pizza
delivered but also there's Knights uh
fighting with
lances and things like that there is a
figure called ballister in the book he
named ballister Blackheart in the movie
he was renamed to ballister boldheart in
kind of an overhaul of his character
we'll get into that he is finding
himself in the position of villain
within the kingdom and he is at odds
with what is referred to as the
Institute and someone finds him this
shape shifter named neona who just wants
to be his sidekick in his villainous
schemes except neona in addition to her
shape-shifting powers is far more
intense in terms of how hard she wants
to do this how far she wants to take the
villain how destructive she wants to be
he's way more subdued than she is but
they bond and they fight The Institute
and there is history between ballister
and ambrosious golden loin who were both
friends and somewhat
Rivals at an earlier point in their
lives but there came a point where in
order to secure his own position his own
future ambrosus did something that cost
ballister his arm and they've been
Rivals ever since you have the director
of The Institute who's sort of an
overhanging villain but there's also
just the general sense from pona of
rejection the sense that she sought out
ballister because Who besides the
villain was ever going to accept her was
ever going to want to do anything
with her much less do things in the
neighborhood of the kind of stuff she
wants to do like destruction now the
movie changes a lot again I'm not going
to go blow for blow but just off the top
of things I mentioned the uh changeing
name to ballister in the book it's
Blackheart in the movie It's bold heart
uh that goes with actually a almost
complete character overhaul ballister in
the film is basically a a wronged man
he is finding himself stuck with the
label of villain and having to work
outside the law by necessity because
he's been
framed there's no framing of ballister
in the novel he's a villain and he knows
that he owns that he still has rules he
still has things that he's not
comfortable doing and that does cause
conflict with neona sometimes but at the
start of this
he's just a bad guy he knows that
everybody knows that the movie he's
trying very hard not to be if you see
anyone murder him hide if you see anyone
hide but he's still finding himself in
that role in that position and the name
change kind of reflects that he's not
blackhearted this isn't who he is he's a
very bold and Noble person in a bad
situation which is not to say that Bower
in the book doesn't have some more depth
to him he absolutely does but it's
presented to the audience kind of the
inverse in each case in the book we're
presented with a bad guy and then we get
some more layers to him as we go in the
film we're presented with a good guy who
comes to learn that sometimes you got to
Break Stuff let's break
stuff the relationship between ambrosus
and ballister which is hinted at in the
graphic novel is made explicit in the
movie and also uh going along with the
framing of ballister ambrosus did cost
ballister his arm but it was in a moment
of panic and a confused situation so it
was not a deliberate choice that was
made although to his recollection and
the Heat of the Moment that was kind of
how it felt in the graphic novel though
how much of it that was the
reality but there's the Mona The Shape
Shifter she goes harder that is true in
both cases there's no slaughtered King
there's no mystery there's no twist
villain in the graphic novel in the
movie we have the director framed
ballister in an effort to keep a
commoner from ascending uh to a point of
power that she feels is profane we have
this backstory of this uh historical
figure of gorth which gets a reference
in the book but is a very minor point it
is a major point in the movie and in
terms of the climax and the destruction
wrought by
neona that happens in both cases the
nature of it is quite different it is
more chaotic in the graphic novel it's
it's hard to even explain basically
neona has kind of been split into two
parts but so much of what's in the movie
just flat out isn't in the book there's
no Squire that they interrogate there's
lots of individual beats that are
referenced or homaged or do occur like
her transforming into a shark during the
moment when she's getting him to agree
to take her on as a sidekick the
Monopoly game that's pretty much
straight lifted uh the fact that she
becomes a young boy for a short time
that's in both places although the
nature of why that happens and how those
scenes play out very different I hate to
say it but you make a pretty good bad
guy there are characters in The Graphic
novel that do not appear in the movie
there are characters in the movie that
do not appear in the graphic novel
there's no Todd in the graphic novel so
the movie is quite different the story
is different the plot progression is
different the climax has a similar
flavor but is fairly different the
ending note is a bit
different
holy so how
am I saying that this is a masterful
adaptation if so much was
changed because it was changed with
purpose and it was changed smartly let's
start with kind of the 800lb gorilla in
the room on this the emphasis and the
bringing forward far more explicitly of
the queer themes you want me to ships
you don't want me to ships pick a lan
and now you're a boy I am today now to
be clear this book lots of queer themes
in here as I said Stephenson was working
through or at least starting to work
through a lot of his own sense of gender
and trying to get a handle on himself
while working on this so those themes
have very much present they are injected
into it but not necessarily on purpose
what I mean by that is when the book was
being written or when it was still a web
comic I suppose Stephen son didn't know
what these things that he was exploring
working through meant the themes were
there but they were there in a they have
to be put somewhere and they're going to
end up here away he didn't fully know
where his life was going he didn't fully
know how much these themes these Notions
of queerness of change of altering
yourself to be more accepted he didn't
know what these things meant the fact
that he was exploring them they were
there but if you've ever known someone
who is queer and is creative and has had
to go through a period of coming to a
greater acceptance of themselves uh I've
gone through this where you look back at
your own creative work in my case my own
writing and realize how much queerness
was injected into it from the get-go
it's there I just didn't know it kind of
the same thing but what that means is
because the movie is made after that has
been completed and after Stephenson has
come to a full realization of himself
and started to live his truth that means
that the movie can have the awareness of
the themes that just arose organically
within the book so whereas the book had
these themes in there as the Creator was
working through them the movie can
go this has those queer
themes rather than just having them be
sprinkled throughout let's lean into
them and really do them and let's do
them on purpose and let's do them big
and let's have that be the point the
shape shifting does it hurt what is
it sorry some mighty question I feel
worse when I don't do it like my insides
are itchy then I shape shift and I'm
free what if you held it in I'd Die good
CL that's horrible I wouldn't die die I
just sure wouldn't be living it's a
really unique approach to take a theme
that is undoubtedly present but is a
little bit more subdued but wasn't
necessarily subdued by choice because
Stephenson didn't know how much this was
going to matter and I'm not going to go
so far as to claim Stephenson would have
made the queer theming much more upfront
and present in the graphic novel if he'd
realized where his life was going he
might or he might not have I will note
that he uh was consulted a fairly
regularly in the production of this
movie
so that to me indicates at the very
least he seems to think that this
approach makes sense to take the themes
that were just there and arose from the
nature of what the Creator was going
through front and center let's really
drill into these let's integrate them
across the whole story make it the point
it to be easier if you were a goat
easier to be a girl you're hilarious I
mean easier if you look human easier for
who there are some who might say that is
lacking the subtlety of the original I
would argue the original wasn't meant to
be a subtle queer story it ended up
being one because of what the Creator
was going through in his
life it is one on a subtle level but it
doesn't need to be that wasn't
necessarily A Creative Choice that's
just what happened so that's the first
thing let's talk ballister so ballar as
I said has gone through a fairly
significant change he's largely just
been softened rather than being someone
who has embraced villainy outright he is
someone who is struggling with the label
of villain and actually has to come to
terms with the idea that the Institute
is fundamentally broken and needs to be
taken down what's it all really for for
protecting the realm Oh you mean from
villains like
you or
Monsters like me the reason this is a
smart change is severalfold the first
thing is this helps play into the
decision to do the queer uh themes front
and center so much more than they were
originally because to have someone who
was part of a
system come to realize that the system
is broken and corrupt that's not
instantaneous to have someone who was
privileged and is now being looked down
on by the system
that can take some time he has to go
through the learning process of no it's
not one bad person at the head of this
the fundamental system is broken and is
failing the people it has failed you it
is failed neona it should not be allowed
to continue he has to go through a
journey to realize that and that gives
multiple queer perspectives to the movie
because you have neona who knows full
well that everything is messed up in
needs to be taken apart and you have
baller who recognized something is wrong
but needs to go through the Journey to
realize just how far that goes which is
reflective of many queer people who grow
up with a certain amount of
privilege
high and enables it to not only go
deeper into queer themes but to have
more than one queer perspective on
everything going on another reason why I
think it was very smart to soften him is
they also had to soften pneumonia a bit
and they then had to kind of soften him
by association what do I mean by they
soften neona well neona kills people in
the graphic novel like from a very early
point and that's actually a point of
conflict between uh ballister and neona
because he has to keep trying to tell
her please stop doing that that's not
how I like to operate I don't want to do
that and I don't want you to she's very
relaxed with killing people they kind of
keep that in the movie in so far as she
suggests that they kill people quite
readily and she seems prepared to do it
but she never does then let's go kill
get them let's go get them in the book
she absolutely does and if you're going
to soften her you then kind of need to
also soften ball because it is key to
the dynamic that she goes harder than he
does so if you're making her softer and
if you then kept ballister about the
same as he was in the graphic novel then
the difference isn't there as much cuz
graphic novel like he's here she's up
here and that Gap needs to be about the
same size so if you bring her down to
about here where she's not so
uncontrollable in her uh intention and
desire to kill people well the dynamic
the Gap is now smaller so we got to
soften him now too so
interestingly though there is a fairly
significant alteration to the specifics
of the character of ballister that was
kind of of done in service of preserving
the dynamic out of softening pona now
you can make your arguments about should
they have softened neona this is
ultimately an animated film aimed at a
younger audience yeah I think that was
probably a good idea to not have her um
just go about casually killing people I
mean if Netflix wanted to fund an rated
cut of this to have them go back and
just have her killing people left and
right I'd be willing to watch it but
it's not necessary and that's not me
saying it was a flaw on the book but the
web comic given the nature of who web
comics appealed to especially back when
Stevenson was writing the this
thing that sort of level of violence in
a uh stylized fantasy world that could
be at a aimed at an audience that is
basically going to be okay with that
level of violence whereas the movie was
honestly kind of targeted a more
specific audience I'm not going to say
that an audience in the age range that
the movie could appeal to should not
read this I'm not going to say that
honestly at all my kid has read this and
seen the movie and loves them both but
what I am going to say is that this was
not specifically targeted at a youth
audience it is accessible to a youth
audience and I think a lot of Youth
audience really dig the hell out of it
but it wasn't targeted at that whereas
the movie was targeted at that audience
and made what I think are some
appropriate adjustments to go along with
it the whole thing of bringing in a
twist with the
director that also serves a pretty
interesting
purpose
because this goes along with the
softening of ballister because he has to
hold at least initially some belief that
the Institute isn't completely rotten so
that he can have a bit more uh of an arc
but that gives us a situation where we
have the death of the queen and now we
need someone who caused this to happen
that gives us the director the director
is in the graphic novel she's a bit more
just um ruthless scientific progress
type she wants to capture pona study
pona make weapons based off pona whereas
the director in the movie just wants to
destroy her again I think this change
works really really well because what
they do leans much more into the queer
theming that they are overall leaning
into much more heavily across the board
in the movie and it also gives her a
reason to go into a motiv a very
different set of motives in the movie
being effectively just rooted in
reactionary beliefs ever since I was
young I've had the same nightmare I
found a crack in the wall and the crack
grows big bigger and bigger until the
wall crumbles allowing ballister to hold
the sword was the first crack in the
wall the idea that things should never
change things have been this way and
they must always be this way and the
degree to which she is prepared to go in
order to accomplish that I beg the queen
not to question the word of gorth not to
question what's kept us safe for a
thousand years I gave the order but
firing them will take out half the city
innocent people will die and so will the
monster and that is the appropriate
villain if you're going to Center the
queerness so much more bluntly than the
book did can't you see this is what it
wants for us to let our guard down
there's the climax and both deal with a
version of pona being massive and
dangerous and angry the movie leans much
more into the tragedy and the sadness of
that with the expanded backstory with
glor smartly neither one truly gives us
a proper origin for her both offer well
maybe it's this but both also undercut
what they offer in the movie there is
the wishing well in the book there's a
backstory with a witch both of which are
pretty much
definitively um
disproven or at least given sufficient
reason to not think that that is what
happened so that means that in both
cases pona is old very old so far as we
can tell she has always been around and
she's been through a lot and you
understand in both cases where her anger
comes from I said neona was softened a
little bit really only in terms of the
fact that she doesn't kill people pretty
much the rest of what she is how she is
how she behaves aves how she reacts it's
pretty exact so the titular character is
preserved very very closely the climax
in the movie and the subsequent ending
is a bit more
uplifting the book goes for something a
bit more Melancholy not devoid of Hope
but neona is gone at the end and I don't
mean dead there's indication she isn't
but she has
left and ballister is just left to
wonder anytime he sees a certain look
from a stranger on the street or if a
cat stops and looks at him for longer
than he feels it would normally he has
to
wonder is that her and if it is I hope
she knows I'm her
friend it's a more melancholy note but
again with the shift onto the queer
themes I think the need for a more
cleanly
triumphant ending and like it's sad for
a bit yes but to get that burst of
Joyful hope at the very end of the movie
holy yeah that should be there the
ending of the climax and the apparent
death of pona which happens in both
cases the specifics differ in the movie
that makes me cry the book it never did
but that's not to say that it isn't
still powerful in the book just that
it's not deliberately going for the
heartstrings in the same way but that
element of tragedy of look at what she
is because the world won't let her be
anything else that's there in both cases
ultimately what this comes down to is
that
the
heart the soul of this book The
queerness the anger the
loneliness the need to fight and tear at
the system that says you're a monster
and wants to either destroy you or use
you for its own ends all of that is
taken from the book given some
shifts given some
alterations but it does all these
changes and it's many changes injecting
new material removing whole swads of
stuff changing most of it but the
central character the heart of the story
both the character Heart of the story
and the Thematic heart of the story not
only preserved but in the case of the
theming the queer
theming
enhanced and when you can take The Core
theme of a piece of work that part of
the charm of it is being a little rough
around the edges and focus that sharpen
it then speaking personally at
least I don't care what specific details
you changed you took what that original
work was saying and you put it on screen
loud and
proud that to me is the key of any
adaptation if you you truly believe in
the original work and it's not just like
oh that's a Nifty idea we could do that
if you truly believe in the value of the
original work the thing to preserve is
the heart of it the details can
change that's fine you can change
backstories you can change plot
progression you can change
names keep the
heart keep the soul
nimona does that
amazingly if you have seen the movie and
not read the book read the book If you
read the book and not seen the movie see
the movie if you have seen the movie and
read the book do that back to back read
the book rewatch the movie Let it sink
in how different and yet how
perfectly the same they are doing it out
of adaptation that varies this much that
still feels exactly like what it should
be is a rare treat in
adaptation and it's one more reason for
me to absolutely adore the movie but
more than that if you find the kinds of
changes made in the adaptation process
to just be an interesting thing which I
do I talk about it uh every now and then
when I find an excuse if the kinds of
adaptational choices that have to be
made fascina you this is a master class
in by most measures drastic changes but
still
unmistakably being the same story
nimona master class in
adaptation an adaptation that does not
need to be slavish to the original but
still gets it
right what do you think about all this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe they all help me out but
don't worry too much about it what I
really want you to
remember is that you are
beautiful you are valid you are
loved you are not a
monster you're the counsel and I'm just
running the meeting and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned shout out to the patrons who
helped make this possible in particular
I want to thank Robin Moore Zubin Lola
goddess Ela Tac the thing that goes ding
to the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures rri Bogden Melinda Walters Jen
Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks kabi LX the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scrapit
angry caspel Dave Hall and Roselyn
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards in the patreon
you can check out the tiers but
um if you are already on the list thank
you so
[Music]
much
down